welcome back is las vegas a seller's
market how is the housing inventory here
with the answers is harvey blankfeld and
he is with las vegas real estate now who
are sponsoring this segment welcome to
the show harvey thanks for having me
back jason okay talk to me about it
housing inventory compared to activity
talk to me about it okay so when the
pandemic started the inventory is right
around six thousand i'm talking about
single-family homes about six thousand
homes available at our market it started
to slip right at the beginning of the
pandemic and and this past uh march and
april was down to under 2 000 less than
2 000 homes available in their market
and then now we've gotten just over 3
000 homes recently uh you can see on the
chart that it was very very low now the
interesting thing about this chart is if
you look at the orange line that's the
activity that's how many single family
homes sold every month pretty consistent
right right in those three thousand but
you saw the inventory was high they went
really really low and now it's coming
back it's coming back is it back all the
way the answer to is it a seller's
market is yes it still is but not as
feverish as it was just a few months ago
how long do you think it's going to be a
seller's market well i think it's going
to be a while yeah i think the demand is
still going to be there and i think that
with that uh creates it creates the
activity you know the laws of supply and
demand dictate uh pricing and the demand
is going to be pretty consistent i think
now before we went on the air you and i
were talking about uh buyers waiving
appraisals are they still doing this
yeah you know one of the uh impacts of
the inventory issue was that buyers were
waiving appraisals entirely when they
were doing their financing they said to
the lender listen i don't care what an
appraiser is that i'm paying the price i
agree to so the seller will sell to me
now they're doing to a certain extent
but now they're capping it they're
saying hey i'll pay above the appraised
value up to ten thousand dollars okay
what i want to tell sellers is this as a
listing agent i would tell sellers if
they're gonna cap the top i want you to
put a minimum on the bottom okay tell
the buyer listen that's okay that i'll
let you put a cap on top but i want
there to be a minimum on the bottom as
well to protect me from this appraisal
coming in so low and that's not a hammer
transaction give me an example so house
is suddenly say a hundred thousand
dollars give me an example 100 000 the
buyer promises to pay over 10 000 and it
appraises at 85 000 so the buyer's now
committed to paying 95 for that home
okay okay you're protecting yourself and
protecting themselves so with the and
what and what the if it had come in at
like 80 or 70 the seller wants to say to
the buyer listen if it comes in much
much lower than that 10 gap i want you
to know that you're committed to paying
at least a certain amount of money
that's what i'm suggesting you're so
full of information i love this
someone's watching right now and they're
planning on buying a home for the first
time what's that one piece of advice you
give them you know meet with a lender
first and talk about your financial
picture get a good idea of what you can
afford go into the market knowing what
your monthly expense is going to be how
much money you have in the bank so that
when you write those offers you know
you're going to get that home
that's the importance you are describing
when my wife and i were looking for a
house we just started looking at homes
let's do this let's do that and then we
went to the bank we're like oh
yeah let's dial it back a little bit and
as a realtor i don't want you looking at
homes you can't afford i'd love you to
buy something but i don't want you to
look home you can't afford it's just
going to be disappointing and i also
don't want you to get homes that are so
low in your spectrum that you're just
not happy with anything you see i want
you to fit into the right spectrum i
want you to find the homes that are just
right for you awesome harvey you're
amazing appreciate you joining us today
thank you las vegas real estate now for
sponsoring this segment for more
information call
702-203-1165 or find them online at lv
lvrealestateradio.com
rocky thank you